the debt snowball you list your debts
smallest to largest you pay minimum
payments on everything but the little
one you attack the little one with a
Vengeance scorched Earth lifestyle sell
so much stuff the kids think they're
next take 16 extra jobs we're getting
out of debt and you pay everything you
stop all investing temporarily and
completely Focus all your emotional
spiritual Financial relational energy on
that smallest debt everything goes on
that when that one's gone you take the
payment that used to be there and any
other money we can squeeze out of our
budget and we throw it at number two and
when that one's gone we take the
payments from one and two the snowball
rolls over again it picks up more snow
and you attack number three the average
person for the past 25 years that has
done that with great focused intensity
gone crazy to the point they broke
friends and relatives thought they
needed counseling they shaved their head
they drank the Kool-Aid they get out of
debt in about 18 to 24 months everything
but their house